GEEKIE.KRAKEN LOOK TO SNA
CHECKED ON THE PLAY.
PROTAS.
LOW TO HIGH THEY GO.
HERE'S GIORDANO.
ON THE WALL.
PARTNER, LARSSON.
AND A GOAL ON A TURNOVER.
IT'S TOM  OF HIM
LEASON.
OFF SOUCY
WALKING THESCHWARTZ.
JARNKROK CUSHIONS THE PUCK AHEAD
FOR
PERIOD.
SCHWARTZ AND GOURDE.
BEAUTIFUL CONNECTIONAK WALKS TH.
POPPING OUT IS AK WILL ADVANCE
OFF A STICK.
AVAIAI NIC DOWD, EXCELLENT
PU PENALTY KILLER.CHANCE.
THEY SCOOOORE!
JARED McCANN WITH SOME.
WE'LL HAVE TO SEE
WEAK SIDE, JADEN SCHWARTZ, AS IT
RICOCHF JENSEN, I BELIEVE
WAS IT JENSEN'S STICK?
ORS JENKINS, YANNI GOURDE,
CALLE JARNKROK, YANNI GOURDE, IN
FRONT  GREAT PASS ACROSS,
ONE!
HE SCOOORES!! GETS THE
DEFENDER TO GO DOWN, RIFLES IT
RIGHT OVER THE TOP THE GLOVE. I.
THE TRAILER, Mc
GOOD IDEA BY JARED McCANN WHO
HASETSOV BACK FOR DENNIS
CHOLOWSKI.
A HAND OFF FOR E E SCOOOORES!
ALEX OVECHKIN CONTINUES THAT
CLIMB UP THE
MISTAKE, PUTS IT HARD RIGHTHE W.
ORLOV.
IN CONTROL.
GOOD DEFENSIVE  PASS.
WILSON.
CARLSON. TIMELY SAVE AFTERHELPE
BLACKWELL.
OPEN ICE.E KRAKEN HAVE KILLED I
OUTSIDE.
JAMIE OLEKSIAK WIL GOING DOWN,
GRUBAUER, STILL AVAILABLE.
IT K OUT TO CENTER, EMPTY
GOOD PLAY, DIVING BACK, SOUCY
WITH A GOOD STICK IN FRONT,